bonjour jean marc merci d'être en direct
ce matin avec nous sur rt france alors
on va parler ce matin des conséquences
économiques des déclarations d' emmanuel
macron sur les différentes phases du
coude et confinement est allé de mai à
juillet a priori est ce qu on sait avec
précision comment et quand la france va
se déconfit n'est parce que tout ça
paraît très flou encore oui vous avez
raison le gouvernement garde peut-être
apporter un quelques précisions
aujourd'hui puisque on devrait connaître
notamment le texte de loi qui réglera
les moyens de protection notamment le
fameux passeport sanitaire mais pas que
le passeport on pourrait aussi connaître
les procédures pour pouvoir organiser
par exemple déconcertait ce en toute
protection un peu comme celui qui a été
lui qui a eu lieu à barcelone et on
faisait état dans le reportage de
précédemment mais pour l'instant donc
c'est très flou pour toi raisons la
première c'est que le gouvernement est
partagé entre le clan de ceux qui
portent les payer ni beaucoup de
médecins
le ministre de la santé le ministre le
premier ministre sont un peu dans le
clan des durs à epiniac temps au tour du
président de la république du ministre
de l'économie aussi qui voudraient
déconfit mais progressivement à partir
du mois de mai pour que l'économie
reprenne un peu son souffle et puis
aussi pour alléger le poids des dépenses
publiques parce que c'est économie
française elle est toujours actuellement
sous perfusion du moins une grande
partie de ces secteurs handicapés alors
il ya une deuxième raison c'est que les
derniers chiffres sont pas très bon on
est à plus de 400 morts par jour avec
40000 cadets gative des flambées du
virus au brésil et en inde qui peuvent
inquiéter j'ajoute que la campagne de
vaccination vous l'avais dit en france
usa la peur des français qui refusent
pour l'instant les vaccins astrazeneca
d'autres on va être en retard
forcément d'autant qu'on n'est pas au
point sur les tests rapides
en bref les chiffres de la pandémie sont
pas bons les mécanismes de protection
sont fragiles dans ces conditions le
besco confinement est floue il ya assez
peu de visibilité
si tout le monde en parle et les
commerçants les restaurateurs quelles
sont les hypothèses sur la table
bah écoutez il ya plusieurs scénarios le
premier scénario bien sûr 6 à
l'ouverture totale vers le 15 mai un peu
comme s'il se passe aujourd'hui en
israël à londres ou même en espagne
comme comment comment beaucoup en rêvent
tout ça c'est pratiquement exclu compte
tenu des chipayas pas à ces personnes
vaccinées en plus même si demain on
décidé d'ouvrir la vaccination à tout le
monde ce qu'il est en pourparlers ce qui
est en discussion on pourra peut-être en
savoir davantage de la fin de la semaine
parce que là on pourrait l'ouvrir à tous
ceux qui veut aller vacciner le deuxième
scénario c'est l'ouverture progressive
des commerces et des terrasses de
restaurants à partir du 15 ml
suppression aussi des interdictions de
circuler et maintien du couvre-feu
c'est sans doute le scénario sur lequel
on travaille actuellement le jeu
raisonnable il souhaiterait même que le
couvre feu
tu a repoussé à 21h par exemple c'est
donc très possible et punir le troisième
scénario c'est l'ouverture progressive
qui restent jusqu'à l'ouverture totale
courant juin tout le monde veut sauver
bien sûr la saison d'été ce qui est
importante c'est que le déconfinement
finalement total doit s'accompagner d'un
durcissement des mesures de protection
par exemple la mise en quarantaine des
voyageurs étrangers beaucoup plus sévère
beaucoup plus sérieuse qu'elle ne l'est
actuellement parce que quand lee roissy
ce sont quand même des vraies passoires
aux as
on va sans doute fermer les frontières
ce qu'on aurait pu faire depuis
longtemps et plus fin juin est bien mise
en place de ce passeport sanitaire qui
indiquerait notre situation par rapport
aux coville vacciner ils étaient sept
circuits devraient concerner 30 à 40
millions de français se passe par vous
permettrait alors d'année en europe bien
sûr mais aussi d'aller au spectacle ou
dans les restaurants au niveau
économique donc ça entraînera évidemment
des conséquences à écouter au niveau
économique ça fonctionne à peu près
actuellement dans tous les secteurs sauf
les secteurs qu'on connaît le tourisme
l'hôtellerie jeux spectacles qui sont
complètement sinistré alors là tout va
dépendre du calendrier parce que ces
activités là ont besoin d'un des
consultants total un restaurant par
exemple peut marcher avec sa terrasse
mais si je veux continuer à perdre de
l'argent il faut qu'ils puissent ouvrir
en totalité et les terrasses elles ne
sont pas extensibles d'ailleurs il ya eu
quelques discussions un peu hard
aujourd'hui avec des municipalités
notamment la miss ming pei paris qui a
fédéré hier soir qu'elle allait refaire
et les terrasses c'est à dire l'espace
public que les restaurateurs pouvait
présenter pour pouvoir exercer leur
activité
il imagine que le ton et les
perspectives sont pas très brillantes à
l'idée de payer comme comme elles
devraient le faire ces terrasses un
théâtre c'est pareil pour être rentable
qui allouait 30 il ya 80 % sinon ça
marche donc ni va recevoir un aspect
temps pour arriver à la vie normale
compte tenu des difficultés de la
vaccination
il faudra attendre septembre et octobre
pour espérer un retour normal ça sera
d'ailleurs qu'on verra le problème de
relance de bruno le maire fonctionner
s'il n'y a pas de mauvaise nouvelle bien
sûr sur le virus l'année 2020 théâtre
encore économiquement très coûteuse vous
savez les chefs d'entreprise ils ont
besoin de visibilité qui est
actuellement la visibilité
elle est comme on le disait prête merci
beaucoup jean-marc pour votre analyse
c'était l édito échos de jean marc
sylvestre